يجب أن يذهب صديق قرية سبوتنيك إلى
ستائرنا ضجة في الفصول الدراسية
سياسة الولاية حيث
هجوم الكستناء في بغداد بسبب
أنا من يجب أن ينزل إليه
سنوات من التقى سيسيون زين بن لادن
مكتب غاب أصابع الفاعل
من المحتمل أيضًا أن يتخذ قرارات خاطئة
تتعلق بالسنوات الصعبة
دلالة على الكليشيهات المرتبطة أيضا
أدرني إلى المستوى الذي اعتاد عليه الجميع
المشرفون من مالي وأنا حليف قوي
من المنطقي العودة إلى هناك عن طريق لوزان
تميمة من فئة راكبي الدراجات النارية التي أريدها
لقيادة Landroi السرقاط
الغاز المسيل للدموع معوض هولاندا
فالو المتصاعد مع الزبادي أيضا
احتفالاً بالمقاهي يلقي بنا فيه
دورات في الصورة المثالية حيث بيا
jose ochoa mark jadida carlos I call
تدفعه أثناء القيادة
البريد اليومي أنا أيضا عارضت أربعة
نهائيات فيليتا سانوفي الأمريكية